salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien cette vidéo c'est l'épisode 2
de ma série documentaire sur le
combattant français de MMA Morgan
Charrière si vous avez pas vu le premier
épisode je vous recommande fortement
d'aller voir sinon vous risquez de pas
tout comprendre j'en dis pas plus bon
visionnage
le soir où je prends ma ceinture c'est
un million de personnes sur W9
[Applaudissements]
c'est des milliers de gens qui tweet
c'est des milliers de gens qui partagent
des millions qui commence c'était le
parfait test pour voir où on était
Morgan
[Musique]
de l'espace en Angleterre
je suis à Saint du SC il faut que je
défende cette ceinture
faut que je les écrase tous et s'il faut
que j'en écrase 10 je vais écraser les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec mon masque au-dessus on a tout un
tas de trophées que j'ai gagné et puis
il y en a d'autres dans la cuisine ça me
permet de à chaque fois que je pars de
chez moi de me rappeler
bah voilà parce que je suis ce que j'ai
fait quand cette fois tous les jours je
vois la ceinture du kit joueur
mais elle est jolie
dis-moi les colis où sont-ils ok c'est
comme Noël j'adore commander des choses
[Applaudissements]
et donc j'ai remporté récemment le type
de problème de France classe Anne c'est
la plastiques professionnelle si j'ai
mon chéri qui est mort
[Musique]
ah ça y est c'est mes lunettes quoi
on a pris des photos avec Arès notre
chien donc on avait mis la ceinture
arrêt au milieu tu vois dans la ceinture
on prenait des photos bonjour
on partait par ses parents pareil il
avait sa ceinture tout le temps avec lui
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps avec
lui
il était tellement heureux vraiment
c'était pour lui c'était un
accomplissement en fait c'est un
accomplissement il savait qu'il pouvait
le faire il l'a fait il a réussi il
avait atteint son objectif
[Musique]
c'est connu tu vois on pouvait pas
partir en vacances tous les deux j'avais
pas assez d'argent vous venez de
délaissant tu vois je fonctionnais par
par plein de
par plein de 10 euros tu vois on va dire
qu'elle me connaît tu vois
là je pense pour fonctionner je pense
qu'on s'est bien trouvé
avec les enfants
[Musique]
elle m'a toujours soutenue énormément je
pense que c'est la personne qui croit le
plus en moi je suis folle comme ça
je pense qu'elle croit plus en moins que
moi je crois en moi
[Musique]
je trouve ça très mignon
avec les réseaux sociaux je peux
vraiment communiquer sur ce que je suis
en train d'essayer de faire et
créer une vraie série tu vois comme tu
regarderais une série Netflix mais de la
vraie vie en fait
l'aéroport
on va aller déposer les bagages et on va
aller prendre l'avion
quand je dis 11 je parle de ma copine
il a commencé YouTube en 2018 Morgan
pour parler de MMA et donc à l'époque
personne faisait ça donc c'était
vraiment le précurseur
les meufs vous êtes toujours comme ça
elle vient de partir aux toilettes donc
là l'avion va voir sur son
il a ouvert sa chaîne Youtube il a fait
des vidéos mais il en parlait pas et
bilan parlait pas mais maman il en
parlait pas ok salut tout le monde ça
fait longtemps que j'ai pas fait de
vidéo donc j'ai décidé de revenir sur la
scène de YouTube comme on dit et je
dirais que ça a vraiment explosé quand
le MMA a été légalisé et puis du coup ça
sa chaîne Youtube c'est un peu plus
développée
on a parlé fait la pas longtemps il me
dit moi maintenant je veux qu'à chaque
combat faire un bec de teaser un teaser
hyper accrochère et je veux que les gens
attendent mon combat mais qui servent
aussi le teaser
pourquoi il y a que les les chanteurs
qui ont le droit de faire des des vidéos
de ouf des clips et tout moi aussi je
vais en faire bon là on est dans le lieu
du prochain teaser je suis rentré par
cette petite trappe échelle monter pour
aller sur le toit ça fait des souvenirs
de fou tu vois imagine mes enfants quand
je l'ai rencontré ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
faites mon père il m'a appelé Morgan
parce que c'est non d'un pirate et je
sais pas pourquoi il voulait absolument
que son fils s'appelle Morgan le nom du
premier pirate qui a annexé elle a
Jamaïque je crois c'était ça l'histoire
qui me racontait du coup à un moment je
sais pas j'ai eu un déclic je dis mais
attends j'adore One Piece c'est un manga
One Piece c'est un manga ou le fille est
le protagoniste le héros et donc il part
de chez lui dans une petite barque son
but c'est de trouver le One Piece donc
c'est un trésor qui quelque part il
commence à être de plus en plus il
commence à avoir un plus gros bateau
alors de plus en plus de gens qui le
rejettent il devient de plus en plus
fort il s'entraîne il combat des gens de
plus en plus fort et en fait j'ai un
parallèle dans son histoire ou ouais lui
cherche le One Piece et tout moi je
cherche l'UFC je monte un équipage comme
lui bah je viens avec mon avis
dans d'autres pays et on fait silence
dans la salle et on repart avec tout ce
qui est à apprendre tu vois donc il y a
rien de plus pirate que ça c'est on
vient on prend tout et on rentre chez
nous donc the l'aspirate ça vient ça
vient de là
[Applaudissements]
il partage sa passion du MMA et il l'a
fait connaître à des gens je dirais
normaux qui se disent ouais mais moi je
peux en faire aussi c'est un sport qui
est ouvert aussi aux gens qui ont un
parcours normal dans la vie qui ont fait
leurs études qui ont des diplômes assez
élevés qui ont une élocution qui
l'aurait rien arrivé de difficile ou de
marquant qui ont fait qui sont tournés
vers la violence Morgan il a jamais eu
d'accident ou de choses marquantes c'est
peut-être ça ça c'est bien pour le MMA
ok du coup là on vient d'arriver
à Sofia on Bulgarie on va visiter un
petit peu je pense et après après on va
aller s'entraîner à 17h
à regarder dans le coach il est déjà en
retard c'est l'équipe gagnante ça
c'était impossible qu'ils aient une
lumière sur eux puisque il y avait pas
de lumière pour ce sport là en France
parce que ici le MMA c'était vu comme un
sport de de chien qui se battent en cage
c'était vu comme comme des voyous
c'était vu comme je citerai Jean-Luc
Roger le président de la fédé de judo
qui disait que c'était un terreau de
djihadiste on en était là en France
quand même il y a quelques années sur le
MMA
[Musique]
moi quand j'ai commencé je savais même
pas qu'on pouvait se retrouver à l'UFC
chez même pas qu'on pouvait être payé
pour combattre tu vois le seul choix
qu'on avait c'est tu fais du MMA tu es
pas mal on t'envoyait au charbon à
l'étranger contre un Russe charger comme
je sais pas quoi dans un endroit bizarre
tu te faisais des boiter parce qu'à mon
époque les Français ils gagnent très
rarement quand ils sortaient du pays
alors les dégâts c'est là j'ai l'oreille
qui est un peu bleu là j'ai la lèvre qui
est très jolie à l'intérieur et là j'ai
une petite boule peut-être dans la
génération d'après il y a des petits qui
moi mes vidéos et ils vont arriver grâce
à moi à l'étape du dessus c'est juste je
veux leur montrer qu'est-ce qu'il en
coûte d'essayer de devenir quelqu'un ou
réussir dans son sport que c'est pas si
simple qu'on peut le croire et que c'est
peut-être pas aussi dur qu'on peut le
croire ok les gars du coup là autour de
l'entraînement donc vous voulez voir mes
repas petit repas du soir du saumon avec
un peu de risotto de la créatine les
oméga 3 très importants les probiotiques
moi un moment je me suis focalisé sur
Twitter j'étais le coach de Twitter
entre guillemets tu vois je j'envoie
plein de valeurs des choses vraiment de
voilà mettez-vous au sport faites si par
exemple je fais des recettes tu vois de
comment tu peux manger quand t'as pas
d'argent mais bien mangé tu vois je
faisais des trucs comme ça je les
mettais sur Twitter enfin je gagne de
l'argent donc je vendais des programmes
en ligne donc je faisais des montages
j'avais une petite commune je commence à
avoir cinq six mille personnes qui me
suivaient
le plus dur ce sera le Tabata à la fin
pour les gens là je reçois
un des plus gros streamers français et
un petit ouais frérot envoie-moi un
programme s'il te plaît je veux perdre
du poids même s'il faut que je mange des
graines je vais le faire je suis mort on
va manger et on va aller dormir et du
coup je dis à Kamel voilà moi je
combattant de MMA moi j'ai besoin d'aide
de force sur les réseaux pour l'UFC pour
que danaille voit que j'existe parce
qu'en France on n'existait pas et je me
dis si j'ai une vraie communauté je peux
faire la différence grâce à ça je peux
faire clignoter le radar UFC genre ah il
y a un petit français là je sais pas ce
qui se passe là-bas mais son nom il sort
de partout
[Musique]
tu fais quoi là du coup je dis à camel
bon écoute je connais pas Kamel j'ai dit
ça j'ai dit viens chez toi
je te coach pendant un mois je
t'apprends tout je te fais à manger et
tout et tu vas perdre du poids pour de
vrai
et on filme tout on met sur Youtube et
comme ça on apprend aux jambes
la flexible la flexible on est
entraînement tous les jours à 11h on
filmait un peu ce qui se passait autour
et on se dit voilà faut vraiment
apprendre aux gens comment on fait une
paire de poids donc moi j'expliquais
tout ce qu'on faisait à la salle genre
quand tu tiens un truc avec le poids là
c'est là ça va être les obliques qui
vont travailler et on a rajouté des
confessionnales
j'ai pas assez j'ai pas de quoi j'ai
plus confiance en moi en fait j'ai plus
confiance en moi assez réel marche de
fou ça explose millions de vues ça c'est
un plat tu peux le laisser servir dans
un resto étoilé frère il est
insupportable deux fois par semaine on
sortait un épisode le mardi et le jeudi
c'est le million sur chaque épisode mais
genre même nous on comprenait pas
je crois que je suis monté à 60000
abonnés en sur chaque réseau Twitter et
instinct en partant de 10000 environ sur
ce merci à tous fin de vidéo n'oubliez
pas de me suivre sur Instagram vous
abonner sur YouTube sur Twitter nouveau
programme qui sort programme Pégase ah
il va filmer
que chacun son tour ferme-moi le combat
mais doucement on s'amène au sol il se
relève je bosse tout ça on sait pas
faire les deux sont les deux en même
temps il y a pas de Tours il y a pas à
toi à moi mais on fait les réglages
c'est disparimline à la touche
[Musique]
oh bah là on commence à intensifier la
prépa ça commence à être un peu plus dur
je vais me préparer par rapport à mon
adversaire il s'appelle Jordan duchesnik
c'est un anglais il a 24 ans je crois 23
24 ans donc c'est jeune ah ça va être
l'équipe assez grand il est un peu plus
grand que moi
la défense de titre pour Morgan qu'on va
Jordan vu tunique qui est un vrai nom un
vrai gars hyper solide enfin faut
vraiment se rendre compte peut-être que
vous le connaissez pas si vous regardez
le docu là vous allez dire que je sais
pas qui c'est ce gars-là mais il est
extrêmement fort
mal il y a de l'explosivité il y a du
bon travail au sol aussi parfois
c'est un bon boxeur assez technique
c'est-à-dire qui boxe vraiment propre
c'est beau avoir fait des belles
trajectoires des beaux correctiligne des
beaux crochets des beaux-up c'est
vraiment de l'école on va dire donc
c'est un combattant qui est assez
complet assez intelligent il faut lui
mettre la pression et c'est lui qui doit
être sous pression et par l'inverse
sinon il va évoluer trop bien il aura le
temps de réfléchir et de s'adapter pour
me pourrir le combat et faire sa
stratégie
donc dernière vidéo avant la vidéo du
combat donc on sait que le combat il va
avoir lieu contre Jordan depuis le mois
de décembre donc ça fait pas mal de mois
qu'on s'entraîne c'est bien entraîné je
suis prêt j'ai largement le temps de
d'être préparé Jordan c'est un très très
bon adversaire j'ai encore approuvé dans
la cage ça me dit prochain malgré que je
sois le champion va falloir que je
prouve que je suis le champion tu vois
je suis pas très inquiet en fait à
prendre ce gars là
je suis pas très inquiet je connais son
potentiel pied point
ok je sais qu'il est bon je sous-estime
personne je sais qu'il est bon mais
Morgan Morgan il a il a un cardio de
malade
[Musique]
Morgan a les qualités Morgan a plus que
toi remporter ce combat là il y a plus
qu'à tamponner c'est c'est une ou deux
dernières étapes auxquelles Warrior pour
s'envoler vers la prestigieuse UFC et il
y a beaucoup de confiance dans le MMA
français à ce moment-là pour que Morgan
continue de grimper dans ce classement
mondial il y a beaucoup de confiance
avant du Scénic
c'est toi le [__] de champion c'est
toi il y a que toi ce soir il y a que
toi qui touche tu l'as lu il touche pas
tu l'as lu tu vois tout tu vois tout tu
vois tout
il va pour gagner pour lui il y a aucun
doute là-dessus mais ici aussi que c'est
quelqu'un qui a une communauté à sur
place et qui sait très bien qu'il va y
aller en terre inconnue ça va pas être
plus faible le favori quoi donc il sait
déjà qu'il faut qu'il fasse deux fois
plus
[Musique]
le combat il commence
je suis en pilote automatique je me sens
super bien
[Musique]
dans ce combat il faisait beaucoup plus
attention
en
[Musique]
uppercut la cannelle par
d'un côté il y a un combattant qui
essaye de combattre qui essaie de faire
du spectacle qui essaie de toucher
l'adversaire en la personne de Morgan
pas forcément qui essaye de gagner mais
qui c'est juste de se dire je vais
bloquer le jeu bloquer le combat pour
faire en sorte de m'imposer donc c'est
pas spectaculaire ça rend le combat
chiant faut le dire vraiment
il est très bon les chenilles qui met du
volume
[Musique]
entre le volume et faire des dommages et
de percutants c'est pas la même chose en
fait c'est ça qu'on va chercher
normalement on fait du MMA
alors pour un combat voilà moi on est
dedans on compte pour nous on est bien
on est en avance on est bien et voilà
dans ma tête je me disais Morgan tu es
devant gère gère
prends pas de risque parce que c'est une
c'est des petits gants c'est du même art
ça peut aller très très vite
on fait les 5 grandes
choses
pour moi j'ai gagné le combat c'était
pas le combat de ma vie mais il m'a pas
mis en danger j'ai très peu de cours
c'est pas passé grand chose toutes les
actions offensives elles étaient de ma
part
donc je m'attends à gagner à la décision
je suis déjà le champion
là où mais le doute c'est Morgan il me
regarde il me dit ça met du temps
effectivement ça met du temps et moi je
regarde et je lui dis non c'est bon mais
je suis dans la cage sur la cage j'ai le
sourire alors j'ai le masque mais j'ai
le sourire derrière ce masque
la décision est énormément de temps à
arriver du coup je regarde mes coachs je
leur dirai ça sent pas bon
là ils sont en train de tous discuter
autour de la table parce qu'il y en a
qui doivent dire non mais tu es malade
c'est pas possible tu peux pas faire
gagner machin et tout c'est beaucoup
trop long la décision
fournisseur
[Musique]
tout s'effondre pour lui autour tout
tout c'est pas mérité
parce qu'il était pas
dans son pays il était en Angleterre
donc c'était plus légitime pour les
Anglais de dire on récupère la ceinture
pour moi quand on va on va prendre la
ceinture à un champion
on doit en faire plus pour moi il en
fait pas plus je regarde le combat
Morgane fort il y a des dommages il fait
mal je comprends pas qu'est-ce qui se
passe
je ne comprends pas
[Musique]
moi je donnais la victoire à Morgan
parce que en terme de dommage en termes
de ce qu'on veut voir dans un combat de
MMA c'est ce que Morgan a fait alors que
vucenic il a on va dire jouer avec les
règles pour pouvoir s'imposer c'est une
décision partagée il y a un juge qui l'a
donné à Morgan les deux autres à vous
Scénic ça veut dire que même dans
l'esprit des juges il y a un doute au
sein des trois en tout cas qui l'ont il
y a pas d'uneanimité maintenant on est
en Angleterre face à un Britannique donc
forcément l'esprit te fait dire qu'il y
a eu vol
ça m'a énervé j'ai envoyé un courrier à
Grand-Bourg j'ai pris ma tablette et je
lui dis que c'était pas concevable que
c'était pas normal comment pouvait se
permettre les juges parce qu'ils sont
trois juges il y en a un je sais il peut
pas saquer Morgan et dès qu'il peut il
lui enlève les ponts c'est pas normal
et je lui dis qu'il fallait qu'il
revient de leur politique avec leur jus
et je l'ai dit à Morgan Morgan l'avait
un petit peu mal pris m'a dit oui mais
je suis plus un enfant j'ai dit non mais
j'ai dit mon ressenti même mon mari
voulait pas que je le fasse j'ai dit je
m'en fous je le fais et je l'ai envoyé
je pense qu'il y a un sentiment
d'injustice de ce qu'on leur aide dans
son ascension son rêve c'est l'UFC on a
arrêté l'ascension d'un gamin qui à ce
moment-là qui est bien en fait
donc il arrête peu d'arrêt
[Musique]
je ferai un peu de temps pour
digérer tout ça et pas dire de bêtises
et tout tu vas pas faire de dinguerie
sur les réseaux sociaux comme vous
pouvez le voir au décor je suis parti en
ressourcer un peu comme on a dit on fait
nous on fait des vidéos que ce soit bien
ou soit mal comme ça vous voyez vraiment
le chemin qu'on doit faire pour
atteindre nos rêves concernant Jordan ça
sert à rien de l'insulter surtout ses
posts et tout parce que c'est pas de sa
faute en fait lui il a fait son combat
il est venu comme un homme tu vois dans
la cage même si au final peut-être qu'il
gagne pas ce combat les juge ont décidé
qu'il avait gagné tu vois c'est pas de
sa faute donc voilà arrêtez de lui
casser les couilles moi de mon côté j'ai
le temps de repenser au combat pas mal
je pense que j'ai fait un combat de
merde j'ai plus le somme contre moi en
vrai que que contre les juges ou contre
Jordan tu vois merci vraiment pour la
force ça fait vraiment plaisir tout le
monde tous les gens qui m'ont envoyé des
messages les gens connus les gens pas
connu voilà vous êtes vraiment une
commune en or c'est vraiment de la
chance de vous avoir et vous pouvez
compter sur moi jamais je lâcherai
franchement jamais
après
[Musique]
direct et je pense qu'à une chose on va
récupérer ma ceinture on a la vengeance
qui arrive quoi
il y aura pas de question parfois je
vais la récupérer la ceinture
[Musique]
et c'est surtout aussi pour inspirer les
gens tu vois ils se disent quand même
voilà j'aurai lâché j'aurais arrêté
moi j'arrive pas à chuter
j'y retourne et je pourrais le faire
sans toi je retourne à 100 fois je crois
[Musique]
voilà j'espère que cet épisode de vous a
plu je vous donne rendez-vous demain à
18h sur la chaîne Youtube de brut pour
visionner l'épisode 3 et je vous
rappelle aussi que l'UFC Paris à Bercy
sera retransmis en direct sur RMC Sport
samedi soir donc voilà ne ratez pas
merci encore pour votre soutien à demain